[Music]
american idol started whittling down the
competition
in a big way on sunday after a round of
show-stopping performances
one of the night's lucky ones was 17
year old hannah
everhart who first grabbed people's
attention for her
uncanny resemblance to katy perry as
well as her seemingly no
gruff personality can you believe you're
even here
no ma'am but i am she is
but you is just like i can't believe you
get ribs at a gas station
but i do last week hannah made headlines
during the duets round when she was
paired with claudia conway
the daughter of former counselor to
donald trump kellyanne conway
together they performed a cover of harry
styles sign of the times
which left claudia packing her bags and
pushed hannah to the next round
i'm going to be cheering for you you
could win this thing
well on sunday's episode hannah stepped
out of her country music comfort zone
and tried her hand at some pop with a
rendition of miley cyrus's
wrecking ball
[Music]
while the performance didn't exactly
blow away judges katy perry luke bryan
or lionel richie
all three judges did see enough
potential to push her through to the top
24.
at 17 i didn't do the work so what i
wish for you in the future
is for you to do the work
know that all that other stuff the flair
the character the sass when you want to
become a real
big time star comes after
so when i see you next time you promise
me some ribs
yes ma'am great well then i promise you
top 24.
the singer was so excited by the news
she jumped
right into a pool i'm talking fully
clothed
in head to toe denim
[Music]
and while hannah might be swimming into
the top 24
viewers seem to be pretty divided over
the teen
one fan tweeted that he was quote hoping
for more fierceness
another added bandana hannah should have
been kicked out
while another counter that her growth
and confidence is showing
murphy we are sorry that we can't take
you forward
but later in the evening there was an
elimination that seemingly united
all the idol fans we're looking at for
their best interests
yeah i think they really know that so
it's nice to be able to
not expect that they're reading our
minds or like we're sitting there trying
to tell them the answer
but we actually get the opportunity to
say and also one last thing
you know after fan favorite murphy
revealed that he has a degenerative eye
condition
that will most likely leave him blind by
the time he's in his 30s
he delivered an original tune titled am
i still
[Music]
but are mine still mine
and despite the sad backstory his
heartfelt performance and
the fact that it was his birthday the
musicians still
ended up getting the axe the fans at
home weren't happy about it and took to
twitter to let the judges know
it's mental gymnastics and it's really
like
it's the master class obstacle course in
a
crunch period amount of time i think
lionel said something the other day you
know
you can't let other talent
psych you out that's right you have to
be what you
are and what you are just because this
person may be
technically the best singer in all of
american idol they may not have the
personality
that you have they don't have the x
factor so
control what you can control handle your
business
but murphy he took the bad news in
stride
sharing this snap on instagram alongside
the caption
quote thank you for everyone that showed
faith in me though my journey is over on
american idol i'll still be singing
tomorrow is a new day and the horizon
looks
very inviting
[Music]
you